wenn jetzt die koalitionsverhandlungen
dreier-koalition ich würde mal sagen
ausbrechen wird es sehr schwierig zu
begründen dass man sozusagen um jeden
preis mit der afg nicht mal reden will
ich glaube wenn die afd
damit rechnet dass irgendjemand auf sie
zukommt und gespräche führen will dann
ist das ein wunschdenken weil in der
jetzigen situation gibt es zwar teile
der cdu die damit liebäugeln aber ich
glaube alles was über über informelle
kontakte hinaus geht ist illusion kein
keine der parteien will eine koalition
bilden
ich glaube das gehört jetzt auch dazu
zum spiel die die die gespräche die es
zu erwarten sind schon mal im
anfangsstadium zu stören
durch irgendwelche quertreiberei
gleichzeitig werden wir
regierungsbündnissen gegenüberstehen die
noch fragiler sind denn es zeichnet sich
ja sehr deutlich ab dass wenn das
überhaupt gelingt in einem fall ist es
noch nicht ganz sicher es auf jeden fall
drei parteien bündnisse sein werden und
diese üblicherweise nicht sehr stabil
sodass wir also eine bärenstarke
opposition sein werden gegen sehr fall
jeder regierungsbündnisse und das mag
sein dass es vielleicht dann auch nicht
über die volle länge reicht keine partei
die eine koalition mit der fdp bilden
würde und auch nicht es gibt auch keine
pläne für eine minderheitsregierung
ich glaube wenn die koalitionsgespräche
jetzt scheitern sollten die jetzt in
beiden ländern geplant sind dann dürfte
alles auf neuwahlen hinaus laufen wie
wir haben ein wahlergebnis das
jedenfalls nicht zulässt uns auf dauer
in irgendeiner weise außen vor zu lassen
wir bestimmen die themen im lande der
protest ist aber glaube ich jetzt nicht
in erster linie dass die leute die afg
gewählt haben auch tatsächlich wollen
dass die afg regiert sondern in der im
vordergrund steht der protest gegen das
was bislang regierungspolitik war das
spielt auch die bundespolitik
ein bisschen mit rein also das große
koalitionsmodell hat meiner ansicht nach
aus gesorgt weil einfach eine opposition
fehlt in westdeutschland hat die rolle
haben die grünen das in gewisser weise
übernommen die afc ist dann nicht mehr
so stark wie noch vor ein zwei jahren
und in ostdeutschland ist es die afg die
da die die die oppositionsrolle
übernommen hat glaube nicht dass die
großzahl der auf den tatsächlich glauben
dass die afd
eine eine funktionierende
regierungspartei wären wir wissen dass
es darauf ankommt wer wird stärkste
kraft wer hat den regierungsauftrag wer
stellt den landtagspräsidenten das ist
gelungen oder ist ein wirklich guter tag
für uns man muss sagen das ist für die
cdu sehr schwer sein wird das ziel zu
erreichen dass ich frau kramp
karrenbauer mal gesetzt hat wieder 40
prozent zu erreichen
weil so lange diese große koalition
besteht haben beide parteien die
schwierigkeiten sich gegen eine
opposition von zwei seiten zur wehr zu
setzen und das wird so bleiben und ich
glaube auch dass die cdu wohl in der
lage ist auf die grünen zu reagieren
weil sie da
anknüpfungspunkte art aber auch der
wahlkampf jetzt in sachsen hat gezeigt
dass sie einfach nicht in der lage ist
auf die afg irgendein konzept zu
entwickeln das dazu führt dass die erste
kleine
[Musik]